and the smartest man alive
doom time
doom time platform i see it i see i love
it i love it
the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
real
and
what was that
it said it's not fondue
oh
now if this is the
nega bands
she just went through the negative zone
cryptocurrency quantum energy is the
future it's the next goal crypto
i want in hope
so as a gesture of goodwill i have taken
the liberty of arranging some buyers for
your life buyers
buyers
one
billion dollars one billion dollars
that's a big who is a billionaire in the
mcu if not victor von doom who also
knows about quantum tank he's got the
money he's got the means he's got the
will
is he will buyers that's a different
franchise
he's got them doom dollas eric he's got
the doombots hey
welcome back to new rockstars as we
brace through the announcements coming
at marvel studios panel at san diego
comic-con this weekend we're coming out
of ms marvel with a mysterious itch and
after you know doing a bit of contact
tracing we realized that patient zero
was a certain latverian who we brushed
shoulders with several times without
realizing that victor von doom is dr
doom eminent in the mcu let's look at
those doom clues
[Laughter]
we need a green blue uh green dog
showing up on the screen for for uh for
blue's clues just kidding that's gonna
be a lot we're gonna find our first
incursion that's the first clue you put
it in your notebook and that's what you
do
this is inside darla oh you can't walk
into the frame now there's a shadow on
the back
i'm gonna have to tell you to go you're
so new
you gotta go
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's weekly marvel reaction show
that you all hate now i'm aaron boss and
with me is mt empty we're now in a gap
period uh but only for a few days
because uh uh city comic-con's coming
and it's gonna change our lives on
saturday how are you feeling dude i am
so excited for just more marvel
announcements like every time marvel
studios has like an event or like or has
a presentation it's always something
exciting it's always something new and
it's always like something to get people
hyped so like i'm hyped for the
potential hype coming very soon
i'm with the mt and i'm not just hyped i
i think i need this i guess i think
right now i'm at uh i'm in an
interesting place with a lot of marvel
fans out there that we we don't really
know where it's going i'm still enjoying
the vibe i'm vibe
i'm having a great time vibing here in
chase four but we don't really have a
sense of the vector they keep saying
like well it's it's this it's actually
this well actually it's this i'll
actually give you clues it's like we
need just kevin feige to walk out on the
stage and tell us what to look forward
to and yeah i'm looking forward to that
i'm looking forward to just a bit of a
bit of direction oh yeah my guidance
counselor i need my mr wilson to sit me
down and say
you're 16 years old but now's the time
to pick your major that you'll be doing
for the rest of your life that's what i
need i just need that uh well ms
marvel's actually in our rear-view
mirror and since uh mephisto technically
showed up at thor love and thunder we
found out we can now move on to our next
big bad dr victor von doom kevin feige
might talk about him this weekend at
comic-con he might not but we have
gotten a number of clues pointing to
doom's arrival in the mcu and in this
episode of inside marvel mt and i are
going to discuss whether doom will join
the mcu from a multiversal incursion or
whether he might have already been
sneaking around the mcu in the 616
universe right under our noses before we
get to doom be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our new latest obsession shirt worthy of
love inspired by thor love and thunder
grey shirt like it's a good shirt like
all of our latest obsession shirts this
one is zero edition and uh um sorry
limited edition
pretty sure pretty sure that's the same
company i don't know but be sure to grab
it before it is gone you can find uh
this and all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
mt
what are we talking about this week all
right man it's the biggest question i
feel a lot of people have had since
we've seen reed richards in multiverse
of madness where is doctor doom where in
the multiverse is doctor von d
like carpet san diego wearing a green
suit and like a wearing mask have been
like jumping off of a building that's
what i need to see sorry
uh yeah i need to see it too i mean and
then we can have a variant of where in
time is kang the conqueror right
i love those games the wearing time and
karma san diego games were amazing it
was yeah i just love the music on those
shows they had that awesome group i
don't know i want to see like a behind
the music documentary about the cook
harmon san diego do up group right
because they um there's you know there's
some drama oh you know no they're all
sleeping with each other
there's fleetwood mac level uh rumors
drama happening behind the music of that
group oh yeah
there's an orgy there's an orgy and one
[Laughter]
his base notes were so low the frequency
no one could hear him say the safe word
right oh no
oh no
this is oh dear this is gross i am sorry
everyone i'm just so sorry i'm just
sorry for everything um all right let's
just get back on track here and start
with a big bit of background on victor
von doom doctor doom was introduced in
1962 in the fantastic four number five
that was when stan lee and jack kirby
really were imagining the guy as a
simplistic personification of death
right uh you know he's got the iron mask
but the cloak hood um but he wasn't
really given a backstory until a couple
years later uh he was a liberian romani
who lost his mother and then went on to
study in the united states and this is
where he met reed richards uh victor at
some point built a machine to try to
communicate with the dead because he
misses his mama but the machine
malfunctions scary in his face we find
out later there was ben graham who
messed with the machine so ben grimm
feels all this guilt like did i actually
you know create this
group says
nothing will nothing bad will happen to
my face my face will be beautiful
forever
he said it it's clobber in time to one
of the screws on the machine and then uh
he said it's clobbering time to stone
zits that's on its face for the rest of
this life um but so doom flees to asia
he meets tibetan monks this is where he
gets the suit he uh and kind of
gets in touch with himself uh becomes
like a badass warrior uh he returns to
latvia he takes over the country and
then at this point he just kind of
fights and and messes with and tries to
kill the fantastic four whenever he can
at one point he tries to shrink them out
of existence uh but he accidentally gets
shrinked out of existence but we find
out later he spent all that time in
micro worlds which is what the quantum
realm is based on in the mcu he takes
over that society as a ruler and later
returns uh to continue tormenting the
fantastic port hooray um actually we
find out in a 2013 run that victor's
mother cynthia actually died due to a
deal with mepisto going wrong now i'm
not forcing him back in there i'm just
saying that you know this is just the
case in marvel comics folks methisto has
like deals with everybody right he's
like
a little jerk who's screwing up
everyone's life yeah um but doom has
really been uh the guy who has had this
reputation of one of the smartest
villains of marvel lore he's a master
both of science and of magic he
understands the multiverse uh
better than anyone arguably than kang i
would say uh and he has he's just really
a relatable villain with this
heartbreaking like variant backstory
right uh and he's just fascinating he
like he's a guy who's just as
comfortable in a castle as he is in a
lab and that's what we really love about
him like that's like my favorite thing
about doom i was thinking about this
earlier today it's like he is the
perfect nexus between uh magic and
science and that's something they bring
up in the first store when um jane talks
to um thor about you know the nine
realms and how they relate to magic and
like dr doom personifies that and i'm so
excited to see how the mcu tackles that
in particular yeah and i think uh the
now that we're coming out of thor 11
thunder that intersection of uh
scientific tech and magic and mysticism
that seems to be a very interesting
thematic undercurrent through phase four
and maybe that can all be embodied in
doom i think in some ways that was
embodied and he remains in kang but
right we just don't know when we're
gonna learn more about kang i think all
these villains are gonna have to be a
fusion of both of these things um but as
we look ahead to the mcu's future doom
plays a very important role really the
central role in the 2015 incursion
storyline that leads into secret wars
he's the guy who's hunting down molecule
man he's using the beyonders and when
all these universes are colliding it's
really doom at the center of all of it
set in a battle world with his doombots
this this multiversal plane where all
the marvel heroes and villains can be
brought back and they fight it out and
they're just trying to
overturn doom for controlling all of
them um but as of this moment in the mcu
just remains unsettled whether
a we will get a movie version of secret
wars i think it's very likely if not
probable um but we don't know yet if
that movie version of secret wars will
be lorded over by kang or by doom you
can see really either alternative right
okay at least it's a more present
multiversal threat in the mcu it's just
hard right now to see why kang would
want all the marvel heroes and villains
to fight in battle worlds but then again
he remains did promise wait till you
meet my variants suggesting that at
least one of those variants is going to
be a madman interested in only in
childish violent delights of pitting
toys against each other as maybe even
that one with a huge massive statue
looming over the tva that could be the
guy who's like yeah yeah i could i could
spend a movie or two on a battle world
um but
in my opinion kang is just more
interesting to explore in the ways he
has already manipulated history and
inspired certain people and saved people
who didn't need to be saved uh and you
know has already just kind of pruned the
timeline in specific ways i don't need
this kind of marty mcfly thing of like
you know kang invented rock and roll so
we found out that jonathan majors
actually told marty mcfly to play that
guitar riff hey i'd be like hey that
actually fixes one of the most annoying
plot holes in movie history where martin
mcfly invented
johnny be good anyway um
i think uh
it's just other interesting places to go
with kang though i wouldn't mind if he
was like the leader of battle world i
just think when it comes to the mcu doom
the multiverse of madness producer's
confirmed reid richard squared portal is
based on dr doom's time platform
confirming essentially that doom exists
in the 838 universe right ms marvel just
showed us the nega bands which i think
might be a negative zone thing we'll see
but i believe mt and i want to hear your
thoughts on this i think dr doom will be
introduced in the mcu
not necessarily part of a cosmic plot
despite the fact that quantum mania is
probably going to show us that city that
might be based on the dr doom micro
world story line i think we're going to
see a version of doom that's more
grounded in a plot on the 616 earth
that's why i come back to sunny birch's
mysterious buyer in ant-man the wasp uh
i think someone who could place a
starting bid of 1 billion dollars for
hank pym's quantum tech sure there are
characters like wilson fisk the power
brokers and their connections the the
ten rings might be able to put that
money together but i think the only
person smart enough to know the science
behind the quantum tech would be victor
von doom i used to think it could be
norman osborne as well but no way home
established that oscar doesn't exist in
the 616 mcu so i think victor von doom
exists in the 616 mcu i think he's been
spending these years gathering all the
advanced technology and get his hands on
quantum tech cree tech stark tech
chitauri tech wakandan tech atlantian
tech mystical objects like the other
bangle the ebony blade i think he is
that buyer keeping brokers like sunny
burch and sharon carter in business and
assuming we finally get a release date
for fantastic four comic-con this
weekend maybe in september of d23 i
think that announcement with it will be
a reveal of the actor who's going to
play doom and i think we're going to see
doom show up in a post-credits scene
within the next year
i'm comfortable enough saying that um
but i want to hear your thoughts how do
you think doom is going to show up in
the mcu well first of all i really like
um that you brought up that like he's
like probably going around and
collecting all of these like really
interesting like energy empowered
technologies and objects and so like we
know from moon night which is something
like really interesting to me when
stephen grant wakes up in the bavarian
alps he's like all right i have this
like he we don't know where the scarab
came from so like it'd be really cool if
like dr doom had a station up in like
what was it sweden
i forget where it was oh i think it
would have been germany right yeah like
if he was stealing from doctor doom like
it'd be really dope if he was stealing
from doctor doom and it was revealed
like retroactively that he was stealing
from doctor doom um but anyway um i
really like that idea a lot but like i
think that we might see doom in the
house of harkness personally because
like we're gonna house of harkness is
likely gonna go into
the witches of the world and like we
know that dr doom's mom like you said
made a deal with um
mephisto and so um yes yeah so it would
be really cool to see maybe like dr
doom's mom play a role in that story and
then doom possibly helping agatha out of
her predicament to for so that she could
help him with the predicament of his own
um because um
we know that uh wanda herself is trapped
in
um
wondergore hell
well like oh she's the last time we see
her she's in wondergore in which is like
in europe and like we know that uh dr
doom is stationed around there as well
so um i could definitely see dr doom
hooking up with agatha and be like hey
help me find this uh all-powerful woman
so that i we could uh manipulate her
together because you're pretty good at
manipulating her um so i don't know
that's just like a weird scenario but
like i definitely think that house of
harkness would be the best avenue for
doom to pop in uh because it's just
mysticism and witches and all that yeah
i think that's a great thought empty i
mean i got a house of harkness i
mentioned it before it's probably the
disney plus show i'm most excited for
the upcoming ones um but i think uh that
would be that's what's so great about
doom is he has these connections to both
the the mystical sorcery-based side of
the world but also the scientific
technological side right um i think
there's absolutely a an alignment
between those two characters that we can
draw together um i think um
uh uh you mentioned something with you
know mount wondergore and we don't know
where in the world that is where right
now
uh what mountain range like it looks
it's so blizzardy and so towering it you
know we can't help but see it as everest
in the himalayas uh where strange was
like briefly banished in the 2016 film
before he could open his own sparkle
portal and get back uh i but i think the
idea is that if its name is wundergor
uh that it would be somewhere in like
uh the alps or somewhere in like the
german alps i don't know or maybe it's
just like some kind of like
hidden realm the way the savage realm is
uh is hidden in antarctica like this
could be some other kind of hidden brown
that just like planes always steer
around there's like a bermuda triangle
vortex there that keeps people from from
walking over there um but uh yeah i
think it'd be interesting if like that
mountain range borders let viria uh and
that i think the way that like the mc
was able to redraw the map to show where
wakanda is in the mcu map um i was
hoping that that map in ms marvel could
have just shown us a bit of like just a
different drawing of uh of eastern
europe right that shows us oh they they
kind of sandwiched in another country
right that must be liberia because like
like various actual location the marvel
comics kind of jumps around to a couple
different spots or different border
countries uh but it's generally in that
area somewhere like
around where like austria is but like to
the east of austria a little bit like
around bosnia in those kind of countries
um but again it jumps around um it jumps
around it jumps around but i
that's why like i i find it more
interesting when the mcu can kind of
like sneakily imply that the world that
we've been living in is already there's
like corners of it we haven't explored i
love that about the black panther film i
was really excited to explore madrapore
in in a falcon the winter soldier um but
i think that they can be a bit more
specific with it they don't have to just
like i want to see maps you know i want
to see specific boundaries and lines and
one thing i liked about ms marvel is
when it showed us that uh 3d display
around the realm fits in over
over the city of karachi i'm i'm just
saying more of that please yes more
geographic visual examples of how this
works
um it wouldn't even require your uh
showrunners and your directors to know
it you could just if it's marvel suit
it's just pain for these vfx artists
artists that they should pay more and
give them more time to work on things of
course but like they could just like put
a map on a screen and then you know that
mt and eric are going to be
crazy
you can even put a sticky note on the
screen for empty and eric
yeah
we'll find it we will find it
um but
this is all a way of saying like we
already have a villain coming from
beyond you know
from another timeline or from some kind
of like citadel at the end of time
whatever you want to call that through
kang i think if we're gonna have doom
enter this universe i don't think he
should enter through like a portal i
think he should come in
just walk in from from stage left right
you know walk out of the shadows of the
mcu that we've already been living in i
think that's more interesting because
then you get to explore rather than oh i
came from another universe the way that
we're exploring with kang you can say oh
i i came from this country that none of
you give a [ __ ] about but you should uh
because my story is interesting my story
deserves to be told like kang is
reclaiming his time that he has and i
can't wait for him to do that i i would
love if doom were to grab agatha and
maybe wanda and use them to actually
take over latveria like i would love to
see like that origin story because like
we know that he takes over the country
in the comics so like it would be dope
he's like hey i need a team i can't do
this on my own so let's take over this
country cause no one's gonna accept you
wanda you just [ __ ] up so like i'll
accept you if you if you help me make my
country um and then like i feel like
that's a really great way to like you
know use these women that are
sort of just
not in good graces of society and just
be like all right come over here i'm
just setting up a new country where
anything i want goes and who's gonna
stop me i'm doomed
basically i like that too i mean what if
we established that uh through the ashes
of sokovia
there's like another
uh militant group in that country that
kind of renames it liberia i mean i
don't know i guess i'm happy with having
both the sokovia and latvia i just think
there's already kind of like a plot
point there where the country of sokovia
it's like there's a memorial there but
like the country is already kind of like
a failed state
so who knows maybe like a new group
takes uh in power and like redraws the
lines a little bit the way that has
happened with a lot of eastern europe
european countries their names change um
well
uh always fascinating to talk to him i
can't wait to talk about him more with
you and yes but uh we have a more we
want to talk about state of marvel on
the eve of comic con 2022. uh before we
do though we want to take helix sleep
for sponsoring this episode of inside
marvel several of us at new rockstar
sleep on helix mattresses and we
absolutely love them helix sleep is a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way that
you sleep everybody's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and burn
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for that spinal alignment to
prevent those morning aches and pains
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you are matched to the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't even need to
go to a mattress store again just go to
helixsleep.com inside marvel take their
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep
inside marble we also want to thank
upstart for sponsoring this episode
we've all been there seemingly out of
nowhere you get hit by an unexpected
expense or a bill just imagine the
avengers every time in interdimensional
race attacks and they are left with the
repair bill when that happens it can
feel like the weight of the world is
coming down and it's normal to not know
where to turn but luckily upstart is
here to help upstart powered personal
loans can help you pay down high
interest debt all online with simple and
easy to understand payment terms upstart
has helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you are more than just a credit
score so rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit your
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com marvel and we want to thank
manscape for sponsoring this episode hey
you yeah you god bush you definitely do
if you haven't tried the best products
from our sponsor today manscaped taking
control of your bush is important these
products are so good and you're going to
be showing pride in your new bush free
yard it's it's a fact that you will have
the best kept nut sack on the cul-de-sac
save big and the most hygienic version
of yourself by using our discount code
of marvel for 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com whether you're looking
to go bald like an eagle or just in need
of a safe trim
is dedicated to helping you level up
your full body grooming game the
grooming package i highly recommend is
the performance package 4.0 inside the
package is the lawnmower 4.0 this
electric trimmer is a bush's worst
nightmare
is this tommy
this has to be tommy it's got to be
this trimmer is designed to reduce
grooving accidents and shave hair on
loose skin thanks to a ceramic blade and
advanced skin safe technology no need
for night vision goggles this trimmer
has an led light to allow you to mow the
lawn in the dark it's basic landscaping
when you trim the hedges the tree stands
taller that's 20 off with free shipping
at manscape.com and use our promo code
marvel it's time you level up from the
amazon to the emma dong with the
ultimate bushwhacking tools
tommy is a national treasure thank you
tommy
amazon to emma dong it's the most forced
pun i think i've ever heard emma dog
that's what everyone's saying during
their ad reads all right mt uh back to
the state of the mcu um so recently a
lot of us at the company been talking
about how multiverse of madness producer
richie palmer said that the main theme
of phase four is quote guilt and
consequences and he said quote phase
four is all a reaction to the trauma of
avengers infinity war and end game and
then he went on to say what happens when
you lose everything right he was saying
that this is kind of a thematic uh
tether with all of the characters and
all the stories we've seen in phase four
i want to ask do you think that's enough
of a theme to fuel a phase with more
titles and hours of content than any
other phase and i asked this because you
know a lot of marvel fans might feel a
little disillusioned right now after
some mixed feelings coming out of thor
love and thunder some people felt a
little mix coming out of multiverse of
madness after shows like ms marvel and
moon knight uh and hawkeye
and uh and what if like i would say
watching one division of loki all of us
i think we're pretty pumped i still felt
pretty pumped after what if but uh all
these other titles
i very much enjoyed them uh i haven't
really had any complaints but i do
understand why people might feel like
well this kind of led me to believe the
whole franchise is going this way this
has led me to believe this going in
another way
i'm not really sure
so do you think fans might feel
justified and feeling a bit
disillusioned and if so what
announcements at comic-con this weekend
do you think could win these fans back
hmm
i think that we're in a weird point
cause we've never really been in
a
phase four before and i say that because
like you know phase one of the mcu
was like the beginnings of everything
like comic book movies were never
anything like the mcu when the mcu first
started so like now that we're we've
ended a saga we ended the infinity saga
with endgame we're at the beginning of a
saga where like so many eyes are
literally looking at this new world of
like the mcu that is starting to form
and so i feel like what kevin feige is
playing right now for a phase four is
like while they explore this this new
the grieving side of the mcu and like
how you how you move forward past this
like terrible like all these terrible
events
you um you need to interview introduce
all of these new characters that um are
going to be taking up the the mantles of
the heroes that will inevitably be you
know leaving the mcu because their
contracts will be up um so like you know
it's basically the new avengers like you
know we're getting our young avengers
being set up with uh um hawkeye and um
stature and all these like uh patriot
all these little little new kids coming
in we have she-hulk and so like i think
that what their plan is is we're
basically in phase one again we're in a
new phase one and so like we're being
introduced to new heroes which i really
love like i love our old heroes and i
love like the stories that we've gotten
because like you know
they're they're the old reliables but
like what they're doing is like they're
we're in a new phase one we're like
we're just introducing new heroes like
your shang cheese your miss marvels your
moon knights and i feel like this is all
sort of coming to you ahead potentially
for me anyway this is my opinion for
civil war ii which i think will be
announced at some point um either this
year in in comic-con or at d23 uh i
think civil war ii is the reason why
they're introducing so many characters
like freaking frogman like i i just if
you have frogmen in the fc you're
literally gearing up like you need as
much heroes as possible i love frogman
but it's just like i feel like marvel
studios just like you i feel like in
every disney plush show they at least
have to introduce one new hero like we
had red dagger we had um um
layla in in the form of the scarlet
scarab like i feel like every show is
going to introduce new characters for a
civil war 2 scenario which i cannot wait
for because i really want that to happen
and i feel like people will be really
excited because civil war like one was
amazing um but yeah what do you think
eric i think that's so interesting i am
definitely hoping for a another civil
war event i think the civil war film uh
did a lot of great things for the mcu
but just left us wanting that uh that
sense of scale that like a true universe
spanning war should have uh i think
infinity war and in game definitely had
that vibe to it but like uh i think
civil war should really be like a series
like a multi-part event right you know
maybe three movies that are released on
disney plus in a year or something like
that i don't know um but i now that we
have all these intersecting tv shows
that kind of occupy their own different
side of the universe i think now is a
great time to do that kind of event
because you really could see how
everyone kind of reacts to it right um
i think maybe marvel studios might have
made a mistake ever using the term phase
four and i know it there was a point
where like kevin feige would never
really commit to phase four at some
point they kind of called phases one two
and three the infinity saga right and
that really excited me because i'm like
okay so now it's not about phase one two
or three they were all part of the
infinity saga so what's this next saga
and we speculated maybe it was the
multiverse saga i think there's a lot of
different ways you could describe it
even call it maybe the rebirth saga or
something like that because i think if
you were to frame it that way a lot of
fans would go into it saying oh so okay
we're just vibing right now we're just
meeting a lot of new people and we don't
need to think of it as like another
phase as part of this installment
chapter system structure that we've been
in um and less eager to be like what is
it all
what is it all leading to like it's okay
if a universe doesn't all lead to
something and you know i remember back
in phase one
we didn't know what it was all leading
to weird yeah it was kind of exciting to
just go from iron man to iron man 2 to
you know hulk was in there thor uh first
guy it wasn't until like they announced
that of interesting was happening
but and we knew when nick fury showed up
that something like that might be in the
future but i don't remember feeling like
avengers is coming until that
post-credit trailer at the end of the
first cap film right then it's like they
showed a trailer for avengers i'm like
oh okay all right i get it i see now
like yeah during that stage we were just
more so happy of just like seeing the
world connecting together it's like oh
my god like is that tony stark in an
incredible hulk film and it's just like
we've never seen so much
interconnectivity between films so like
we were just happy that that was
happening and then when avengers hit we
were like what and then the post-credits
scene of avengers is when the big hype
came when thanos was like oh
i exist it's like oh we're going aliens
now like we're really yeah obviously
avengers 1 was an alien film but like
thanos was like well no we're committing
to like a cosmic saga of the mcu like
the mcu is now bigger than it's ever
been and so like ever since then um
that's when like the hype really really
builds um but yeah so i i wish that
marvel studios could kind of like uh and
maybe that is what comic con is all
about and maybe kevin feige has been
saying that all along we just haven't
really been listening but i think uh
rather than calling this phase four i
don't think they should call it a phase
because the reality is we are getting so
many more hours of content just from
these what has it been six seven disney
plus shows that we've gotten or are
getting so far and just more and more on
the way to say that like that type of
storytelling is on par with the six
movies we got a phase one separated in
some cases by years uh i don't think
it's it's really fair to compare them um
but i do get this idea of people feeling
like thematically a little
uh
turned around because this idea of like
a reaction to infinity war and in game
like
i i'd love uh if this were truly that
then every episode of every new show
should have uh catching up with a
character either coming back from the
blip or experiencing them in the moment
of the blip and i've loved every time
that like they've done that in the mcu
whether it's the elena bulova or monica
rambo i could watch a whole series of
just like blip stories um but that
doesn't necessarily seem to be the case
for all these characters i think it's
this series or this phase has been about
like introducing us to new people and it
feels a bit more experimental and that
we're just gonna see who sticks i i
honestly feel that
intro the introduction of characters
like scarlet scarab and red dagger
um and uh kazi and hawkeye a lot of them
just feel a bit inco inconsequential
right like of all of them the ones that
have like stuck the most with me have
been monica rambo uh kate bishop
obviously but i think she's pretty much
a title character on this show but like
characters like sharon carter you know
the uh even like johnny mayonnaise like
a lot of these characters are just like
cool like yeah i'll i guess i'm excited
when they show up again but they haven't
really like
persisted in my in my you know the
frontal lobes of my brain uh as much as
like some others have
um and often like i forget they exist
now characters in loki for whatever
reason like i would die to protect b15
and kc and sylvie and ren slayer like
dave for whatever reason oh i guess i
mentioned monica rainbow i think agave
harkness has been the biggest breakout
new character oh yeah i'm so sure like
the most beloved out of the end
of the character from disney plus i
think absolutely yeah um i don't know if
anyone else has really come close to
like agatha and monica rambo in my
opinion well morbius i'm
[Laughter]
yeah mobius is up there rubies is up
there for sure um yeah so i think like
that's why i'm uh eager i think the
announcement at comic-con this weekend
that would just get me really pumped is
like
what the next
like if we learn what the fantastic four
subtitle is going to be you know see if
it may ant-man wants quantum mania it's
fantastic if we're gonna have something
under there
i don't know if mutants would be like
i'd be super excited to see if they
announce who the new x-men are going to
be or certain of the new x-men are going
to be i'd certainly be excited but
unless they tell us like the context of
how all these characters are going to
meet
or run into each other what the conflict
i just want to know what the conflict is
going to be right um because i can
already guess who the characters are
going to be um like you know i'm just
more interested to know like what is
what are they going to be dealing with
right
um because that gives us a sense of the
scales so
it doesn't have to be secret wars you
can call it whatever you want um but uh
if you want to call it battle world if
you want to call it incursion if you
want to call it honestly i think a
better title will be something like
multiverse war avengers multiverse war
avengers multiversal war uh something
like that um then i'm like okay and then
i can understand i can see the the code
of the matrix i can see how it all fits
in but until then yeah i get it uh i do
feel a bit wandery but i also don't
really mind wandering through the desert
a little bit because we're having these
fun moments along the way we're vibing i
was vibing throughout ms marvel and
enjoying it yeah i feel like this next
saga if there's going to be a name for
this next saga i feel it's going to be
the secret saga because like we're
getting secret wars we're getting secret
invasion um we might even get a secret
empire and like i just feel like um
there's all these like shady
organizations in play and like we're
getting all these like multiversal
people coming in like i just feel like a
lot of secrets are going to be happening
and so like um
and especially like these encourage like
secrets
don't tell um yeah especially because of
these incursions that are happening
which are a huge deal in the marvel
universe because like
basically multiverse of madness
guarantee that like the mcu is going to
die or like or something seriously bad
is going to happen to the mcu to the
point where like it's going to start to
break down
and um it's probably going to involve
the crossing over of heroes that are
going to have to fight one another to
survive which is one of my favorite
parts of how secret wars even begins in
the in the comics it's like man ultimate
universe is fighting 616 for the right
to live and like that is so fun and like
i really want to see 838 have to fight
with 616 for survival because i feel
like that's what's going to happen and
like that would be exciting
the fox x-men universe fights yes like
fox x-men universe like freaking
spider-man universe like all this like
that's what secret wars is all about
it's these earths coming together for
like the ultimate civil war scenario
where it's like i we have to survive and
we were just trying to fight to survive
and so um yeah like i i'm so excited for
that but like i just want kevin feige to
come out on stage and be like yes this
is what's happening get excited for this
because like i just feel like we need
that we need that direction because we
are sort of lost it right now i agreed
but we're still enjoying it i like i
love just floating with you emt right
we're in a lazy river of content and
we're
we don't need to go down any slides
we're oh we're older gentlemen now we're
just happy to see my background
that's a fast uh
we'll leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel thank you all so much for
joining us this time next week mt and i
will be back talking about some major
news coming out of comic con most likely
um until then you can follow us on
twitter and wherever else at eavos and
mastertainment you can subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast you can follow new rockstars on
social media rockstars thank you all so
much for watching thank you we'll see
you next week
bye everyone
you